the top Republican in Congress is
tearing into one of his own tonight
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
says Iowa Republican Congressman Steve
King might want to consider getting a
new job last week King was quoted by the
New York Times as we've reported here
saying white nationalist white
supremacist Western civilization how did
that language become offensive King has
since said he rejects such labels and
that was a rookie mistake
this afternoon McConnell said there is
no place in the Republican Party the
Congress or the country for an
ideologically I the ideology of racial
supremacy of any kind I have no
tolerance for such positions and those
who espouse espoused these views are not
supporters of American ideals and
Freedoms representative King statements
are unwelcome and unworthy of his
elected position if he doesn't
understand why white supremacy is
offensive he should find another line of
work
also today Illinois Democratic
congressman Bobby Rush introduced a
resolution to censure King House
Majority Whip Jim Clyburn says a
reprimand will do President Trump says
he has not been following the
controversy in late this afternoon House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy met with
King so far no one involved is
commenting on that meeting